hello friends welcome back in this
episode I'm going to cover the move
Knight to f3 against this our approach
is universal we are going to play the
Moody file and now why it has three
interesting choices amongst them Knight
captures d5 is a not a good move because
straight away black and equalised after
the following order that is Knight
captures Knight pawn captures Queen
captures t4 and now the move Bishop to
g4 so we enter into one of the
transposition of the Scandinavian
defense where not only black has develop
is all three pieces but that can easily
castle on the next move and then look
out for the quick movie file then short
White has given up the advantage
straight away in the opening so that's
why Knight captures D fire is not
recommended at this position the second
interesting move what can try over here
is e captures D file which I personally
found out very very interesting here I
recommend that you should capture this
one and now White has three good choices
the first move I want to have a look is
Bishop to c4 well against this I am
recommending that you should play the
move Knight to b6 immediately attacking
the bishop and in one crazy game
my opponent try this sacrifice which is
Bishop captures f7 I'm including this in
this lecture because you never know some
psycho play against you so you should
know what exactly you are going to do
about it
here you should certainly capture this
piece and the whole idea of the white is
to pro this check with the move Knight
to g5 and the best place for the King is
to place on g8 afterwards White is going
to play the move Queen to f3 here black
should continue with the move Queen to
e8 defending the critical f7 Square and
my opponent responded with Knight to b5
so his idea is pretty much clear he
wants to capture the c7 pawn and then
foking my queen and rook well it looks
good but after the move Queen to g6 I
think White has a long term problems
that can be seen in this game my
opponent captured the c7 born thinking
that I have to move the rook but here
comes the Big Shot
that is Knight to d4 so not only hitting
the Queen but this night and the c2
squares are also hanging after long
thinking my opponent players only good
reply that is Queen to f4 so protecting
his Knight but then I continue with the
move Knight capture C to check King to
Devin and now the strongest more of the
game that is ePHI kindly note white
cannot capture this pawn because at the
end white will lose extra night so
that's not possible and in the game my
upon responded with the move Queen to f3
but after this the task is very easy I
can capture this rook and when really
capture the rook I can snap up this
Knight and you can see after the whole
complications black emerge with two
piece advantage so this is one wonderful
line if you open place the psycho type
move Bishop captures epsilon the more
subtle replies are Bishop to b3 against
this I am recommending a very crystal
clear plot so what you are going to do
over here is you first of all play the
move Bishop to a5 the general line goes
with the castle on the Kings side now
you played the movie six of course White
has to finish his development so he has
to play the d4 to free of his other
Bishop here we will continue with the
move Bishop to e7 the most aggressive
response by the white is to play Bishop
to f4
so pressurizing the c7 square no matter
we are going to castle on the King side
and now you don't need to afraid of the
move Knight to be file the simple reason
is black can play the move rook to see
it not only defending the c7 square but
we are soon hitting that night with the
move a six so that's not a good move the
main line goes with the move rook - even
afterwards we have a very simple but
very effective law
what we want to do is to play the night
to the ephah and then look out further
move c-file and if you can manage to
play the C Phi at the right time you get
a comfortable and a slight advantageous
position to see this let me show you a
model game which will highlight what are
the problems white is facing in this
line here I immediately responded with
the moonlight to e-file my opponent
plays the MU s free stopping Bishop to
g4 idea i immediately captured the
bishop and when he recaptured I give a
flight square form a king as well as
Bishop in case if it's attacked my
opponent responded here with the move
Knight to e5 which is a typical move
whenever white has this sort of space in
the center but this is exactly the right
time where we are going to hit back into
Center with the move C Phi after long
thinking my opponent find nothing better
than capturing this form I recapture
with the bishop and now he doesn't want
to play the move Queen to e2 when
defending the c2 square so instead of
that he decided to exchange the Queen
and then put his night on the e4 square
which at first sight looks tremendous
because it's attacking the bishop and if
black wants to save the bishop then he
has to retrieve back either to e7 or f8
well that's not the case black captured
this night and when white recapture the
piece now black has this amazing move
that is rook to see it so you can
already see this two rooks are very much
aggressively placed there is already
ongoing pressure on the c2 squared and
although white has managed to bundle up
this piece on King side but they are not
actually doing anything furthermore
black has created a threat that is white
cannot capture this a 7-point in fact in
the game my opponent fall for this one
he captured this pawn and now I'll give
you a few minutes over here can you
identify a motor which will give black
upper hand
okay I hope you find this smooth that is
Fi the whole idea of F is this rook is
right now protecting this bishop and
after the more fire this route can no
longer protect this bishop so in the
game my opponent plays the move rook to
even but now comes the tactics that is
Knight to defy simultaneously attacking
to piece which white cannot defend both
of them if rook to a4 then defy is a
very strong move so in the game my
opponent decided to capture the b7 but
after Knight captures f4 black emerge
with a piece ahead and white has some
pawns on the Queen side but they are
[ __ ] pawns and after some
complications I managed to convert the
full point so that was a model game
which will highlight what are the good
plants for black in this system now the
second move I can try over here is
Bishop to b5 but this is rather a dull
move
it's okay white can manage to double the
black pawn but same time white lose his
bishop pair so I don't mind this and
against this I'm recommending that a
simple idea that is a knight capture c3
if you operand plays the move Bishop
capture c6 at this point then I
recommend that you should play the move
capture c6 and after B capture c3 you
should play the move Queen to defy Black
has this double pawn but so did as white
and not to mention black has a bishop
pair also white has to play very
carefully for example at this point if
white foolishly castle on the King side
then after Bishop to g4 we will create
another set of double pawns on the White
King side so that means at this point
White has to place the more h3 and now I
am strongly recommending that you
exchange the Queen with the move Queen
to e for the simple reason is after this
exchange of queen black left with the
bishop pair and that can be a very
critical factor in the endgame so that
was about immediate Bishop captures c6
the stronger over here is B cap to c3
afterwards I am recommending
that you should play the move Queen to
defy so hitting the bishop now if you
opponent defend that Bishop with the MU
c4 way for let's say for example with
the MU c4 then after Queen to e4 check
Queen to e2 exchanging the Queen and
placing the bishop on the d7 it is black
who has the better pawn structure and
why it has a long-term problem to
resolve this double pawns
so that is why c4 or a four is not good
the most critical line is Queen to e2
but after this I am recommending that
you should immediately place the move
Bishop to g4 if white is giving us
double Paul so what we are giving him
back one of my internet game goes like
this so my opponent responded here with
the MU c4 I responded with the move
Queen to a5 and now he give me this
double pawn which I happy accepted and
then he plays the MU T 4 for a moment it
looks like black has this weaknesses but
we are about to create weaknesses on the
White King side first I responded with
the move rook to d8 hitting the d4 pawn
my opponent defended with the move c3
and now I place the MU c5
so you can see this weaknesses can
easily be dissolved by such a more my
opponent plays the move Bishop to e3 I
capture this pawn and then again hitting
with the mu E Phi now if I created a
threat that black wants to play the
movie 4 so my opponent
destroy this pawn with the D captures
ePHI but this is exactly block once
black can complete his all piece
development with the move Bishop to b4
check kindly note this bishop cannot
come to the D 2 square so White has the
only reply laughs that is skiing to f1
afterwards
black and simply castle on the Kings
side my opponent continuing with the MU
s 3 I place the move Bishop captures f3
he recapture with the Queen hoping that
I am going to do a queen trade but not I
played the move Queen to e-file and we
should stop over here the simple reason
is yes
material is balanced but the only big
difference over here is look at
this wonderful rooks they are connected
and look at this disjoint rooks and a
pathetic cake only black can play for
advantage in such a position so that was
all you need to know against the move
Bishop to b5 the most critical response
over here is to play the move d4 but the
good thing from the black perspective is
more or less all this kind of setup we
are going to play the move Bishop to f5
and if you operon plays the move Bishop
to c4 then there will be a transposition
of the line of Knight to b6 so the only
independent move over here is to play
Bishop to d3 no matter we are going to
capture this Bishop when white recapture
with the Queen we are going to play the
movie 6 so it's the same setup we take
out this Bishop outside the pawn chain
then we play ecigs then we play Bishop
to e7 then castle on the Kings side and
then quickly go for the C file kindly
remember this plan in your own game and
you will have a very very comfortable
given now once again I like to show you
a model game in this line where my
opponent was 2100 plus and he responded
here with the MU castle on the Kings
side I responded as per our usual plan
so I played Bishop to e7 he responded
with the move room to even I castle on
the Kings side and now indeed black is
threatening the Moon Knight to b4 if
white plays the passive moves such as a3
then I recommend that you should capture
this night giving white double pawn and
then simply play the move Queen to d7 if
you play a species like this you will
have a very very comfortable game White
has a hard time to prove his advantage
so probably understanding this at this
point my opponent decided to capture
this night
I capture with the Queen and now my
opponent's idea was to play the move C
for tremendous space in the center no
matter we can play the move Queen to d7
and now he responded with the move
Bishop to f4 so this is you can say one
of the most aggressive set up by white
white has delphi's all minor piece and
he has
tremendous center but black is rock
solid and black does not have any
problems now this game will give you a
very good idea that tactical
possibilities in this kind of setups
here I continue with them rook F to d8
so attacking the d4 square and my
opponent obviously defended with the
move rook to d1 so at first sight it
looks like white is all good and it has
a wonderful position but that can be
illusion the move I played is Knight
captures d4 BAM so always look out for
such a possibilities now let us know if
I can capture with the Queen the simple
reason is black and reply with the move
Queen to a4 so hitting the Queen hitting
the rook and if b3 then the simplest is
capturing the Queen and when white
recapture the Queen and you can capture
the piece so white has some structural
deficit and not to mention black is a
clear pawn up so this is a winning
position for black so the obvious move
after the Knight captures b4 is Knight
captures night well after this we are
going to play the move c5 regaining of a
piece
my opponent responded over here with the
move Queen to g3 which is a very very
tricky move his idea is that when I
recaptured my piece he can throw this
surprise that is rook to d4 very very
cheeky the thing is if you foolishly
capture this rook then after the move
Bishop to e5 you have to give up your
queen and the game so obviously I didn't
fall for that
after long thinking I come out with a
stronger move that is Queen to d8
hitting the rook now the engine suggests
here the base move is Bishop to e5 but
after this move I am recommending that
blacks should continue with the f6
hitting the bishop so that more or less
obliged white to give up the D file and
when Bishop drop backs to the c3 then
you can play the movie file so black has
more attacking chances than white in
this kind of scenario
instead of these he played the obvious
looking move that is rook to d1 and it
looks very natural doubling your rope on
the D file and do not give up the D file
but in fact this move turns out as a
disaster I wonder if you can spot it I
give you a few minutes over here try to
identify what is the problem and this
move okay I hope you find this move that
is rook captures before and after rook
captures d4 d5 hahaha amazing pawn
sacrifice and you should always look out
for such things in your own game so
what's the big idea the first thing is
white is obliged to capture this point
because it's foking to pieces so after
the move Bishop captures efore now the
idea reveals that is AB 6 and after
Bishop to f4 Bishop to c5 so one way you
can say it's a clear and sacrifice by
sacrificing upon black has created a
tremendous counter plane so you can
already see this rookie's attack there's
a back rank made his exists in other
words white has the only reply there is
rook to d1 and now Queen to e2 attacking
two spots so white has the force reply
that is rook to c1 and now rope to d8
another thread that is rook to d1 and
threatening a checkmate suddenly from
nowhere just giving up upon black
activity is completely rolling down on
the King side it is very clear over here
that might have to do something about
his background so my opponent obviously
played the mystery I played now the
second attacking move that is root 2 d3
hitting the Queen and now Queen has to
stay in touch with f2 otherwise after
will drop so the only move left is Queen
to h4 once again I like you to pause
this video and find out our move which
will clearly give a winning advantage to
the white
okay the move is h5
unbelievable in fact this is not the
move I have played in the game after
some complication the game was initially
drawn but when I was analyzing this game
with the fritz engine I was amazed that
black has this resource that is h5 okay
so let's see what is the big idea of
h-file now let's see some moves further
so these are the best move suggested by
the engine that is why it has to place
the Mook to have fun
afterwards black will play the move
Bishop to d6
and after Bishop captures Bishop now you
can see the whole idea behind - Phi
Black has this wonderful move G Phi
trapping the sweetheart now the third
critical try y can done over here is to
play the move e5 but this is less
dangerous than he captures d5 the simple
reason is you can guess blacks next move
yup it's d4 same old story which we have
done against the MU f4 as I have already
mentioned that white cannot give up the
ground by playing the move Knight to e2
the simple reason is black and play the
move Knight to g4 and if black plays the
move d3 over here
then the simple is capturing this fall
at just a normal game where black has
thrown this horrible move d3 which
actually why doesn't want to play and
instead of d3 if white plays the most
obvious looking move that is c3 then
after d3 Knight to f4 hitting the d3 we
can capture the e5 pawn it's not that
black can hold on to this point but it
is more relevant to the position so
white can get its pawn back after this
sequence that is Queen to a4 check
Bishop to d7 and then Queen to e4 so
obviously black has to save his piece
with the move Knight to g6 but after
Knight captures Bishop to c6 and Queen
to e3 we can simply reply with the movie
six and it's a laughable position for
white
none of his bishop can come out and on
the next move black and play the move
Bishop to d6 and then quickly go for the
kingside castle and then get hell loose
on the white key so obviously this time
around we get the same position except
the difference is and therefore
variation White has therefore pawn in
this variation White has this Knight
posterior f3 which is a kind of better
than f1 but anyways that does not
discount our plan of campaign we have
the pretty much same plan against both
white setup now here I can also capture
with this Knight but moving the one
piece twice is not recommended so other
two moves needs to be considered if you
oppor and place the move Queen captures
d2 then the very obvious is you exchange
the Queen and capture this g7 pawn with
the bishop and after White Castle on the
Queen side this is all I have explained
in my previous lecture you can
immediately play the move Bishop to g4
if all out then black can double the
white pawn so the generally why defend
with the move Bishop to e2 and now you
simply castle on the Queen side with a
very very comfortable game
now one thing white should not do in
this variation is to play the MU H 3 and
after let's say Bishop goes back to the
H Phi goes for this Bishop with this
water that is g4 Bishop to g6 and nitro
h4 this has happen in one of my game but
this is a complete disaster the simple
reason is black has a very strong reply
over here and that is Knight to d4
hitting the bishop with check and the
same time hitting the c2 the only way to
defend this both threat is to play the
move Bishop to d3 but after Bishop
captures pawn captures White has this
horrible weakness on d3 which is more
than enough for black to create a
winning chances so instead of this why
should play the move group to e1 but
after this we can simply reply with the
mu e 6 with reasonable winning chances
the middlegame so that was about Queen
to d2
the most obvious response is Bishop
captures d2 we are going to capture this
pawn which force white to play the move
c3 and now we play our trademark move
that is Queen to d5
here I like to show you one of my model
game which will give you ideas and plans
exist in this line
my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to e2 I responded with them 'if i
he castle on the King side and now I can
play the movie for so this is a very
ambitious set up by the black here in my
opponent responded with the move Knight
to even I complete my piece development
with the move Bishop to b6 he responded
with the move Bishop to f4 hitting my c7
square and now I simply castle on the
Queen side we should Scout on the Queen
side as quickly as possible because we
have the open G file and that means we
have a very good chances to attacking
the White King side in this game my
opponent exchanged the Queen which I
happily accept it and now he plays the
move Knight to c2 so it has a very
cunning idea to read out the knight in
the e3 square and attacking my rook
so I counter this with equally sneaky
move that is Knight to e-file
he continued with the moonlight to e3
but this is exactly I want I played the
move rook to d2 hitting two spots which
white cannot defend both of them so he
tried to do some complication with
Bishop captures ePHI Bishop captures
Aoife and Bishop to c4 doesn't matter i
greedily capture that pawn he captured
my bishop which give me double pawn on
the e-file and now I have a threat on
the c3 square which my opponent defended
with the move rook to c3 and then I
played rook to f8 hitting the f2 hear my
opponent goes wrong he thought that he
can play this move that is Knight to g4
same time defending the f2 and hitting
the bishop but after some depth
calculation I come out with a very
strong move that is H Phi
so the reply is force I am giving up
this piece for tremendous mating attack
with start with the move rook captures
f2 my opponent responded with the move
Knight to c4 but you are about to
witness breakdance by white key so
following moves are like this so finally
King has set down on their fun and now
the whole idea will reveal because my
monster H born will roll down to the h1
and checkmate white key and believe it
or not but white is completely helpless
he continued with the move Knight to b3
I counter attack his Knight with the
MOOC to g3 he defended with rope then
the obvious mu has three occurs
he finally tried to activate his rook
with the Mook to d1 but it's too little
too late I capture another pawn giving
away 2 - ball he played rook to d4 and
the final blow has to somebody stop me
so they can - okay I hope with this
wonderful brief analysis you can play
confidently against the move Knight to
f3 it's time to look out the most
critical move d4